Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Arrow Episode 6 video. Whole bunch
of Legends of Tomorrow setup, so everybody
chuck your vodka out, grab a glass of whiskey
and let's go! Just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet and just
a reminder my reverse flash ring giveaway
is new this week all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so this is a whole bunch of magic
stuff in the back half of the season that
there teasing with Damien Darhk but mostly
this is like legends of tomorrow stuff starting
with top five WTF Felicity versus all the
city of I love that Felicity was so pasted
herself for going away with all of her I feel
like this is a big strike if you hey Felicity
this is a big episode for you everybody on
the team has their own demons that they deal
with and you don't really see them until they
get super stressed out like when Thea goes
crazy because the bloodlust like Sara did
in this episode were last season when all
of her one super crazy that I can't be with
you can't be the arrow and be this Oliver
Queen guy then he came full circle and they
were together at the end Felicity achieved
that same art within the same episode that
you know thanks to help from her mother what
I think the writers are staying with this
is that there is not to be any kind of wedding
rings happening anytime soon that still exist;
price to come up so eventually when they do
break up and I definitely do think that they're
going to break up for the end of the season
you just see them part ways amicably like
look we have a bigger responsibility were
gonna have to put this thing between us on
hold Marc Guggenheim at the beginning the
season was like well their relationship will
last longer than it has in the past which
I think is just code for yet there'd they're
definitely get a break up pretty soon my favorite
Felicity moment though was just like at the
beginning of the episode when you see her
in a trash pile of Cheetos and energy drinks
I feel like there's a missed opportunity for
an integration there like I I hope their brand
integration manager was calling Chito's like
look we have a ton of cheetahs in this episode
please send us some money on the number for
the Baron writer in the flashbacks is looking
for a gift from the ancients what it is we
have absolutely no idea just it is somewhere
underneath the water in that Coke there at
this point the flashbacks are mostly like
an afterthought but II do think the connect
more with modern-day real soon I'm just expecting
those markings that Baron writer uncovered
to connect with what's going on with us of
the Damien Darhk has like his magical artifacts
even if one of the objects the Damien Darhk
has is not on the island but I think that
all of her will learn something that will
help him deal with Damien Darhk later they
did say the one of the flashbacks to be a
little bit more independent of present-day
like that they didn't want to have characters
from the flashbacks show up in present-day
so with slightly more disconnected that is
been in season's past this thing with Elysa
Rotaru this actress here that's going to continue
to develop that she might wind up being something
of a spiritual guide for all of her with without
him realizing it on the number three though
hey mom totally love you no spoilers please
in case you forgot the last time she showed
up in town and she told Quentin that she was
now dating someone and living in Central city
so we might see her in a future episode of
the flash or they might remember for her at
this point she's on the level with all of
her's child like I'm not expecting her to
come on the show anytime soon but she definitely
still exist that she still there really I
think the biggest casualty in the episode
was team arrow progression because they spent
most of the time developing what's going to
be going on with legends of tomorrow next
you know setting up the atoms shrinking ability
setting up Sara to become the white canary
like giving her reason to go away like I had
this bloodlust have to go away and deal with
it I need some time your quota quote time
to deal with it shall have all the time she
needs pretty soon the evening tease that on
rip Hunter's time ship which I haven't seen
pictures of yet is sexy like a really big
ship there's going to be something of a romance
between the Adam in the white canary but on
my number two WTF Mister terrific and Felicity
head into battle so is always a little bit
selector scenes are mostly meant for comedy
Mister terrific remind the cities in Olympic
medalist in the decathlon suite is actually
pretty bad ass but there mostly using him
for comedy on the show so push comes to shove
in a future episode or like the back half
of the season will probably see him throw
down and kick some serious ass but I love
Felicity's joke before they headed in were
she's like I don't think that our company
health plan covers supernatural dismemberment
you as you're them reference magic in some
way I like I like the consistency even when
Damien Darhk was fighting all of her which
was actually more of a distraction usually
just there to keep Damien Darhk busy but on
my number one WTF Damien Darhk reveals the
next stage in his plan for the city he unfolds
his box and it looks like it's magical circuitry
like there's mechanical parts that require
the dwarf star alloy to be power but there
also magical rooms but here's a bit of a stretch
it looks a lot like the markings on her mother
box now that would imply really really big
big things that I never thought that arrow
would ever be able to do but they're doing
legends of tomorrow the doing time travel
time Masters I guess they could do new gods
it is certain point some of the fantastical
things that Jack Kirby's fourth world would
fit a lot better in this TV universe that
they have been in the super serious movie
universe but I never think in a million years
that ever be able to do like a real version
of Darkseid or the new gods or anything like
that so it remains to be seen what this actually
is but it does look like circuitry in what
kind of tiny box shaped object do you know
about that requires dwarf star alloy levels
of power to activate there just aren't that
many things in the DC universe that I could
think it would need that so I do think that
he's going to use that box as a portal of
sorts like he talked about breathing new life
into the city into this world cackling villain
monologue now within like the arrow flash
legends of tomorrow universe we haven't seen
a lot of the spirit world or demonology or
any of the characters associated with those
comics like Adrian so I'm curious to see if
Damien Darhk is communing with someone like
Trigon like a really big figure in the DC
universe or if it's gonna be someone that
they just make up like someone original to
the show Baron Reiter specifically called
out to the ancients and that's kind of a generic
term we don't know who those are but I'm guessing
that's also who Damien Darhk is trying to
work with let me know in the comments though
what you think Damien Darhk meant when he
said breathing new life into this world and
it just to talk about the post credits like
there was just like a little bit of post-roll
obvious that the Adam went off these like
Felicity you can be charged that come back
from the dead more legends of tomorrow set
up an easy detective Lance with Felicity's
mom not really expecting anything big to go
on there and you can look into that is much
as you want but they did confirm that Theo
will have something going on with his campaign
manager is much as Damien Darhk is gonna royally
screw everyone at least I'll have somewhat
to make out with his the world comes to an
end a lot of time going around on the flash
and arrow this week I feel like as we get
closer to sweeps week that's a big week for
advertisers the United States that's when
you tend to see the more sensational things
happen so like he starts the more people have
sex you see the big crossover episodes so
like that's why next week on the flash were
gonna see gorilla Grodd you can be huge special-effects
episode and then they'll be a week break and
then the week after that in December were
gonna see the big crossover episode than the
midseason finale's there's actually a ship
ton of DC universe marvel universe and Star
Wars universe stuff happening in December
they're going to drop a new trailer for Batman
view Superman which is actually coming out
in March which is like way earlier than big
movies like that normally do we get the first
trailer for Captain America Civil War and
X-Men apocalypse dropping with Star Wars the
force awakens so it is going to be like the
biggest December I think we've had in a long
long time but I'm in a try and do is post
agent to shield tomorrow morning then there's
new Star Wars footage and hopefully I'll have
time to do Supergirl video to disable save
I get three videos out tomorrow I don't know
these can happen but white as way for that
stuff you can click here for this week's episode
of the flash if you haven't seen it yet Zoom
versus Barry so much fun and click here for
the Jessica Jones trailer that I just posted,
so much David Tennant creepiness gonna be
so awesome thank you so much for watching,
everybody high five and I'll see you guys
tonight!